worried about the dives at the downs of
today
yes I'm not concerned about that at all
I expected that a little bit because
people don't understand quite yet about
what's happened we've taxed China on 300
billion dollars worth of goods and
products being sold into our country and
China eats it because they have to pay
it because what they do is they devalue
their currency and they push money out
our people haven't paid as you know
we're also charging them 25% on two
hundred and fifty billion dollars so
we're taking in many billions of dollars
there's been absolutely no inflation and
frankly it hasn't cost our consumer
anything it costs China now what has
happened is a lot of companies are
moving out of China so they can have you
know avoid and China has had a rough 20
this is their worst year in 27 years
according to yesterday's Wall Street
Journal I don't want that but when my
people came home they said we're talking
we have another meeting in early
September I said that's fine but in the
meantime until such time as there's a
deal
we'll be taxing them we're just kidding
and we're getting very good numbers from
the border the 21,000 soldiers supplied
by Mexico and I want to thank Mexico
they're doing a great job the numbers
are way down at the border
I think it's very much under control
very much under control well what would
you say it is let me ask you a question
right right right right
sure sure what would you say when China
for the last 20 years has been taken
hundreds of billions of dollars out of
our country and we had a president that
would never do anything a number of
presidents that never would do anything
about it what would you say for many
years China has been taking money out by
the hundreds of billions of dollars a
year we have rebuilt China so now it's
time that we change things around if
they don't want to trade with us anymore
that would be fine with me would save a
lot of money no I don't know I think I
think President Xi who's somebody I like
a lot I think he wants to make a deal
but frankly he's not going fast enough
he said he was going to be buying from
our farmers he didn't do that he said he
was going to stop fentanyl from coming
into our country it's all coming out of
China he didn't do that we're losing
thousands of people defense at all and
this was time and very importantly for
many years you know this better than
anybody you've been covering it for a
long time for many years China has been
taking out hundreds of billions of
dollars a year and rebuilding China it's
time that we rebuild our country you
know the one thing I have to say and you
have to say this what China's doing is
they're devaluing their currency and
they're pumping money out like they've
never done before and they're paying for
these tariffs we're not
are you concerned by reports of the
Chinese army may be preparing to
intervene in Hong Kong against
demonstrators and what do you say to the
accusation that the US well something's
probably happening with Hong Kong
because when you look at you know what's
going on they've had riots for a long
period of time and I don't know what
John is added to it as somebody said
that at some point they're going to want
to stop that but that's between Hong
Kong and that's between China because
Hong Kong is a part of China they'll
have to deal with that themselves they
don't need advice no no no September one
the reason is it takes a long time for
the ships to come over and it's a period
of time so I'm giving up four of like a
four week period of time before the
tariffs go on but we're now taking in
tariffs on 10% on over 300 billion and
25% on two hundred and fifty billion and
it's been proven that our people in that
Bank for those terrorist
[Music]
short range missiles we never made an
agreement on that I have no problem
we'll see what happens but these are
short-range missiles they're very
standard go ahead what go ahead
congressman Radcliffe is an outstanding
man and I'm sure that he'll be able to
do very well I think he's just
outstanding highly respected by
everybody that does we've not changed on
well way we're not allowing Huawei into
our country we're not changed on that we
can do business for non security things
with Huawei because that's you know
we'll do that but anything having to do
with national security we're not dealing
with Huawei what do you think about the
decision to not prosecute James Comey
for legal well I haven't actually heard
that I know there's a lot of things
going on that's a piece of it I guess
but I really don't know I haven't spoken
to them about that I would frankly be
surprised because what James Comey did
was illegal so I would be surprised but
I don't know anything about that
[Music]
today are you prepared to tell your
supporters to stop if they begin
chanting something problematic I don't
know what's going to happen I can tell
you this I'm going to Cincinnati the
arena is a very large one and we've sold
it out we could sell it out probably ten
times from what I hear the the
applications for seats as you know never
had an empty seat the applications are
very big I have no idea we have a great
group of people they love our country
they love the job we're doing and when
they see the kind of people that want to
represent us from the last two nights
that's not what they want I don't know I
can't tell you whether or not they're
going to do that chant if they do the
chant we'll have to see what happens
well I don't know that you can't stop
people I don't know that you can I mean
we'll see what we can do I'd prefer that
they don't but if they do it we'll have
to make a decision then my message is to
the people of going to so we had over a
hundred thousand applications for
whatever the size of the I think it's a
fourteen thousand seat arena but we're
way over a hundred and I think a hundred
and twenty-two thousand applications for
those seats you know what my message is
I love them and I think they love me I
actually think they love me
India has - we will
[Music]
have they accepted the offer or not well
that's up to it's really up to Prime
Minister Modi and I met with Prime
Minister Khan I got along great with I
think they're fantastic people Khan and
Modi I mean I would imagine they can get
along very well but if they wanted
somebody to intervene or to help them
and I spoke with Pakistan about that and
I spoke frankly in India about it but
that's been going on that battle for a
long time but if somebody if I can if
they wanted me to I would I would
certainly intervene yeah
I can't comment about that but he was
very threatening to our country he was
saying very bad things about our country
I will let you make your own comment
about it but I don't comment but I will
say hamsa bin Laden was very threatening
to our country and you can't do that but
as far as anything beyond that I have no
comment last week that wasn't
interfering in u.s. elections right now
could you wave that with laughter oh you
don't really believe this do you believe
this name okay okay fine we didn't talk
about that I spoke with President Putin
of Russia yesterday they're having
massive fires in the in their forests
they have tremendous I've never seen
anything like it is very big I just
offered our assistance because we're
very good at putting out forest fires
frankly and if they should need it
I offered our assistance we had a good
talk a short talk but a good talk and I
think he appreciated it
so we would be able to help them it's
these are massive fires like I haven't
seen that was the primary importance of
the conversation and I think they I
think they very much appreciated
well I watched Muller I'm not sure
Muller knows what's going on you want to
know the truth but all I do know is he
said no collusion with us no collusion
and ultimately no obstruction because it
led to no obstruction by a very smart
group of people including our Attorney
General so no collusion no obstruction
as far as Muller's performance you would
have to say it was maybe not so good not
so good so our country's doing very well
we're setting records in every way
including employment unemployment we
have now more people working in the
United States that ever before the stock
market it will take a little hit but it
will be phenomenal because ultimately
it'll be much better because of what I'm
doing somebody should have done this
with China a long time ago they decided
not to do it they made a big mistake but
I will say this there's never been a
time in the history of our country like
we have right now the highest number of
people employed the best employment
numbers for african-american Hispanic
women for everybody I mean the best
numbers we've ever had our military is
being rebuilt and it's almost fully
rebuilt it's going to be at a level in a
very short period of time stronger and
better than ever before with new
aircraft new missiles new everything
hopefully we don't have to use it go
ahead we defer to what did you think of
the democratic debate last night Biden
and specifically the charge from
congresswoman Gabbard that you're
assisting out item so yeah nobody knows
what she meant by that I've I think even
you probably didn't like that statement
John she doesn't know what she's talking
about if you remember a short while ago
I defeated Isis we have a hundred
percent of the Caliphate so you know
you're always going to have somebody
around we're right now we have captured
over 10,000 we have 2,500 Isis fighters
that we want Europe to take because they
were going back into Europe into France
and
Germany into various places so we have
right now 2500 Isis that we captured
we've captured 100% of the Caliphate and
we've done a big job on al-qaeda and
everybody else so for her to make that
statement is ridiculous frankly for her
to make that statement is so ridiculous
and she's taking a lot of heat on it
because nobody has done more against
that war than I have so we have
thousands of Isis fighters that we want
Europe to take and let's see if they
take them and if they don't take them
will probably have to release them to
Europe after what he's done this week
said what because these are short-range
missiles we never discussed that we
discussed nuclear what we talk about is
nuclear those are short-range missiles
yeah and a lot of other countries test
that kind of missile also so interesting
because everyone says he that's so tough
and now you're saying I should have done
more look I did more than anybody
thought with the first 250 billion and
the 10% is for a short term period and
then I can always do much more or I can
do less depending on what happens with
respect to a deal but I'm very happy the
way it is right now my people came back
they're going to meet again in September
I said look if you meet that's great but
in the meantime we're gonna pay a tear
they're gonna pay a tariff and it'll be
a very substantial turf now if you
remember when I did the 25% I did it in
stages and this can also be lifted
ultimately in stages or it can be taken
off but it can be lifted in stages so
we're starting at 10% and it can be
lifted up to well beyond 25% but we're
not looking to do that necessarily but
this would be done in stages so I put on
10% on 300 it's approximately 300
billion we already have a 25% tariff on
the first 250
so the 10% follows the 250 billion a 25%
thank you are you considering a blockade
or quarantine of Venezuela given the
amount of foreign involvement that
worked up China and Iran yes I am yes I
am yes yes
out never practice it they run along
you know it's interesting nobody's even
mentioned this question to me it's so
long until last night at the very end it
wasn't even mentioned in the debates
people aren't even thinking it's a hoax
I don't know if you know that you know
it's a hoax right so nobody's mentioned
it to me one thing I will say that you
haven't covered two days ago a highly
respected judge in the Southern District
of New York in Manhattan came out with a
decision on the whole Russia hoax and he
said exactly that it's a hoax
you want to read the decision this is a
decision by a judge who's highly
respected who was appointed by Bill
Clinton when he was president and he
came out and he said it's a hoax and
that's exactly what it is this was a
case brought by the Democrats against me
and nobody wants to talk about it you
know why because it's fake news
about the ioan app breeding we didn't
discuss the INF mostly we discussed the
forest fires in Siberia and other parts
of Russia and I said look we have the
greatest equipment if we can help you
let us know large sections of burning
and so I said to President Putin we can
help you let me but we're pulling out of
the treaty tomorrow well we'll see what
happens I will say Russia would like to
do something on a nuclear treaty and
that's okay with me
they'd like to do something and so what
I
[Music]
well I think that listen I've been I've
watched Elizabeth Warren sometimes
referred to as Pocahontas with her pony
try at an ancestry that she didn't have
I've watched her and I don't know to me
she doesn't have credibility it's
possible I have to run against her but
everything she did was a fraud she got
into colleges she got teaching jobs she
said she was up Indian heritage it
turned out to be alive
so Elizabeth Warren really has a big
lack of credibility which
I didn't really know I didn't look I
think that Kamala did not do well last
night I think that I think Biden did
okay he came through he came limping
through as I say about slicky Joe even
then right through it but he got through
it he really did I think he was okay
I think Kamala had a bad night last
night I would say but it's really
boiling down to four or five of them
let's face it I don't well I have a lot
of respect for falling as you know the
people of Poland like me and I like them
and I'm going to be going to Poland very
fairly soon and I know they're building
an installation that and they're putting
in all of the money 100% of the money so
they're building something very nice for
the United States to have go ahead
what
[Music]
no I think the responsibility is the
people that have run Baltimore for so
many years
obviously headed up by Elijah Cummings
they've run Baltimore into the ground
we've given billions and billions of
dollars to Baltimore the people of
Baltimore appreciate what I've done for
them by bringing this up it's the number
one city proportionately
in the United States on crime I saw a
statistic where it's worse than Honduras
right now and I think what the people of
Baltimore I think they really appreciate
what I'm doing the money was stolen or
misspent or wasted and a lot of things
happened a lot of bad things but the
government for many years has been very
good to Baltimore we have to help the
people Elijah Cummings has not helped
the people but maybe at some point we'll
get together and we'll get it
straightened out but what happened in
Baltimore is disgraceful and it's not
only Baltimore it's other Democrat run
cities and you ought to report on it
sometime thank you
[Applause]